review it review it do it review it Evil
Dead is the remake of the Evil Dead
which was directed by Sam Raimi and
starred Bruce Campbell these guys are
returning to produce this remake now
that film was a big inspiration for a
lot of independent filmmakers back in
its day that movie showed that you could
do a lot of really innovative stuff with
makeup gore and really well-done
direction with an extremely low budget
and still get a lot of tension out of a
movie and that spawned a lot of sequels
and a lot of fans and so people are
really anticipating this remake now for
me with remakes I try not to get too
excited especially with horror remix
because generally they are terrible and
Nightmare on Elm Street Halloween
they're not good the remakes of these
classic films rarely ever live up to the
original and most of the time they're
not even good alone on their own right
this movie has basically the same plot
as the original there are different
flourishes that are thrown in there some
of them actually improve upon the
original for instance there's actually a
reason these people are going to this
cabin this time and it's you buy it you
actually okay I get what these people
are there and because of the reason
which I won't spoil they're able to
actually give a lot of excuses for why
they don't initially leave when stuff
gets really weird and some of it
actually like oh you know what that
actually is a pretty good idea I would
have I wouldn't have thought of that and
it added a little bit of credence to the
whole why are you obviously leaving this
cabin there's a problem here but going
into this movie at this early screening
that I was able to see and I was very
excited to be able to see this early by
the way I wasn't really expecting much
because I didn't want to get my hopes up
fans of the original and horror fans in
general will probably be very pleased
with this remake this is definitely
something that was treated with care you
can definitely tell that Sam Raimi and
Bruce Campbell were involved with this
film they were producers and you can
really feel that there's someone behind
the camera who definitely loved the
source material it's actually very well
directed there's a lot of really good
sequences in this movie and if you loved
the original or if you're a horror fan
in general you will probably leave the
theater with a big old smile on your
face and you'll probably also want to go
home and take a shower because wow
there's blood there's blood there's a
lot of blood blood blood
but this is a bloody movie Wow so if
that's what you wanted going in that
will also make you happy because I have
never seen so much blood in a movie in
my life I don't think Wow now one of the
things this movie had going against it
was the fact that last year and would be
called the cabin and the woods came out
and the cabin in the woods was very much
so a spoof spin-off on Evil Dead or
horror films in general but definitely
Evil Dead I mean the whole there going
to a cabin they find a book and all
these items and they read from it and
things start coming live out of the
ground and everything I'm happy to
report though because you can tell this
film was actually made with care a
director who knows how to direct a movie
there's a lot of really good shots in
this film and the film looks great the
director of photography did a fantastic
job lighting this movie and creating
atmosphere and tension through his
visuals I was very impressed with the
way this film looked and yes there is
definitely an aspect of this film where
you think I've seen all this before but
you can't really escape that when you're
making a horror remake it's just going
to happen you're going to have things
that you're going to expect fans will go
into this movie to see an updated
version of what they love and for them
they will probably really enjoy this
movie and I found myself enjoying the
film too despite the fact that I'm not
really a big fan of gore gore gore I
know that fans will definitely
appreciate it and it wasn't like a
hindrance on the movie because it's
something that I know that they were
really going for one of the things I was
very impressed with in this film was the
practical effects there's barely any CGI
at all and for that reason the film felt
a lot more intense and more brutal and
more realistic it's like in the original
film they just had a whole bunch of
practical prop make up stuff and they
did the same thing in this one obviously
they had a better budget and more
updated materials and for that reason
stuff looks more real than it did in the
original film I just like that they
didn't do a cop-out and make everything
all CGI and everything they did a really
good job with that there isn't some CGI
thing crawling up the ceiling and doing
weird flips or anything it's basically
like 95 percent practical and for that
reason I was very impressed the score
for the movie is also pretty good as
well the whole film has a good
production to it it sounds great it
looks great
now the problems with the film are
basically problems that most horror
films have extremely weak
characterizations really stupid
characters that you don't really care
that
much about aside from the lead girl and
possibly the lead guy but there's a
blonde in this film that you honestly
don't I don't even know what her name
was like she was apparently the
girlfriend of the main character or the
main guy but you don't really know a
thing about her and that's essentially a
thing with most horror films that most
people on the screen are there to be
killed in some sort of horrific way I
would have liked the characterizations
to be a little more strong but I
wouldn't say that it hurt the film in a
drastic way I think that people who go
into this movie who want to see
something that treats the source
material with respect who want to see a
well-made remake that actually treats
the original with care they will be
pleased it's just a very well made
horror film and a remake that actually
respects the original I'm going to give
Evil Dead a B if you're a fan of the
original you will probably love it if
you're a fan of horror films you'll
probably enjoy it too I myself loving
scary movies had a lot of fun with this
movie as well so I hope you guys check
it out if you want to see it thanks as
always for watching guys and if you
liked this review you can click right
here and get stuck man eyes
you